today we are taking a quiz to find out
which common voting facts are actually
total lies so we know and you know do
you know a lot about voting I know a
tiny tiny bit
I go to vote mostly from peer pressure
and I have you like an obligation that's
your right I actually made a show for
BuzzFeed and one episode was all about
voting so if I mess up I should have my
America card revoked
is that what it's called no we're
basically gonna figure out which one of
us is smarter in voting in garden yes 10
question quizzes I love a good deal good
drag and just rip me apart I don't know
nothing about a good student yeah the
myths the truths and the falses question
number one it is illegal to cast a
ballot before Election Day starts true
or false true because absentee ballot
because that's what I do for South
Carolina wait let me get false wait then
they answers false trains the saying oh
yeah yeah yeah false
what about mail-in votes you could do
early voting nah
oh yeah early mornings if it's literally
oh wait before lecture yeah okay yeah
it's possible
yeah sick I knew it yes you can usually
vote before Election Day many states
offer early voting every state offers
absentee ballots that you can fill out
ahead of time and mail in however each
state has different rules and some
require a valid excuse to obtain an
absentee big I'm just not ready and I
can't come maybe like you're away at
school schools different state you want
that's the first question I like like is
so far one out of what number two Oh
Marie reading convicted felons are
banned from voting anywhere in the u.s.
convicted felon oh this one why are you
I could have picked it bad no I think
that's true only because a guy went to
high school with who was a convicted
felon said that he can't vote so I'm
pretty sure in some states you can
actually vote while you're in prison and
also afterward though I'm gonna say true
but I hope it's false I am pretty sure
it's false so I watch documentaries and
documentaries have taught me so much
especially the 13th about you know
America's pipeline prison systems and I
hundred percent believe that it sure but
maybe some convicted felons I don't know
all right
like what's inside of their pellet taxes
you don't pay taxes break it down with
you yeah I am in this right now a little
nervous so I'm not gonna look all right
that's true
I think it's false actually it's varies
by state by state and Florida has the
craziest laws about it it's a great
question because it says anywhere the
key word it's a hot topic right now
really I think so all right ready
[Music]
wait what what what see it is common
misconception that people with felony
convictions are never allowed to vote
again in reality the laws on this
totally vary state by state you can
learn more about this on your state laws
here oh good first dee had forgiven us
resource sets cuz he has a link clicking
believe me it has been common practice
in the United States to make felons
ineligible to vote in some cases
permanently over the last few decades
the general trend has been toward
reinstating the right to vote at some
point although this is a state-by-state
policy choice so of course in Maine in
Vermont
those are some cool places I love you
for Allah
love you well yeah shout out to Vermont
I mean the mountains just make me want
to write a folk song yeah guy in Florida
should hit him up send him this quiz
okay good that's fishing
absentee ballots are only counted if the
election is closed yes true yeah you
know what I recently learned that this
might be true so we'll see but I
actually whatever right mister why I am
literally just overheard this I'm not
sure but I think true because I think
the person I heard this from is
trustworthy that likes to know sense
that would be false
I don't feel responsible right now yeah
that's gonna be pop I hope that has no
idea I'm gonna also hope that Falls feel
like everyone's vote should count
you're both wrong total BS absentee
ballots count just as much as ballots
submitted at the polls as long as you
make submissions that makes sense that
was really done that week is like dice
kind of like well the biggest thing
about it is like all right number four
that's you okay college students are
allowed to vote in the state where they
go to school oh I should know that the
first time I got to vote was my freshman
year of college I remember I had to do
an absentee ballot I think because I
went to angle out of state I had to vote
in my home state where my driver's
license with registered so I'm gonna hit
fault I think wherever you're registered
to vote is where you have to vote so if
you're registered where you go to school
then that's real of a trick question
I never went out of state but I think
this is true because college students
usually don't have like money yeah I
think it's true - it just depends on
like where you register to vote any
registered vote somewhere without a
naturist Canadore me an address
yeah it's a box but you have to
re-register yeah
[Music]
so yeah what no students can vote where
they go to school the Supreme Court has
ruled that students aren't evil and
above their school estate alternative
leave and register in your home state
and what absentee okay so that's what I
did okay okay I have questions I'll look
at the link later nice we got this one
oh yeah okay cool yeah you can do it
freakin do it
some states have made it illegal to take
a selfie in the voting booth I know that
that's true I heard it's true there are
legal documentation in there it's gotta
be true was President and people were
taking like little videos with I'm
voting for Obama oh my god the fact that
that's even a question is amazing that
can't be true I think that can be true
because then this whole thing maybe
border was like border fraud thanks for
enforcement standpoint like booth is
monitoring people taking selfies in the
to do something like in the bathroom
stall codes right all right I just
frowned upon I don't think it's illegal
cuz like don't do it
shame on you if you do but if you do it
you won't get caught why should it enjoy
I think it's fine if you do yeah I have
no objections with it I heard maybe it
just like pace up time that you're in
the booth and there's a long line and
people are just trying to get in there
deck some people try to get creative
with the boomerang and leg trying it
like their finger in or I hike a hundred
selfies to find a perfect one the only
reason I wouldn't do it is like if I'm
voting for somebody who I'm ashamed I'm
voting for I'm like I don't
then you should take a selfie world if
you want to this is false
I usually go early so it looks like
puffy and and that's why they give me
the stickers you take a selfie with a
sticker that's right ready for selfies
be wrong yup that's true snapping a
photo in the voting booth in your
polling place or of your ballot maybe be
illegal in your state but there's lots
of other ways to let your friends know
that you voted yeah it's correct because
it's like important documents and like
you're not supposed to be sharing at OHS
I can't like write a picture and be like
would you poop from the moon yeah more
don't she they gave me resources I just
want to know what states are doing this
that's crazy I cannot believe that you
can take a selfie I feel like that's the
first amendment and the first you can
avoid jury duty by not registering to
vote
oh I had it a few months ago it's coming
have you ever done - no I have not I'm
gonna say boss I think that's all
because you get I think when you get you
maybe when you get your driver's license
yeah I think you're just in the system
regardless you know getting at that
right because if I think this is false I
don't think anyone can avoid jury duty
but registering to vote you're being a
good citizen so that they they consider
you oh they're good enough into the
citizen to also be a voter Oh but and do
jury duty so maybe if you don't register
both they're like well then you don't
get to do your civic duty I'll say false
because they'll find you and I think I
feel like those have to be two separate
things we're cooking false because we
feel like Jay Duty is an intricate
system that we have experienced yeah we
know we've done we've done we know that
you're an assertive oh yes yes okay good
false
yes great this only makes sense like if
this was true no one would sign up to
vote and it's already hard to get
because early polls voting needs to be
made easier not more difficult which is
a big problem in this country currently
correct sorry it's not that easy
a variety of sources may be used to
select potential jurors including tax
rules state IDs or driver's license
databases and well participate list you
might as well be registered to vote
because you can still be called up for
jury duty
and you want to pick your leaders so no
excuses you your dude Jan unless you
like off the grid and not registered and
in some states you can vote online or
via text I wish I don't think this is as
you know the kids would do it then yeah
thanks for sure would old people love
going in they loved writing pen to paper
that yeah feels good I think it's false
if it's sure they also but it should be
true but also like you can spare skin
like spook technical text some
suspicious so I want to say Falls I mean
everybody talks about hacking every year
through the thing automated systems I
don't think we doing tech swimming but I
know probably that this cannot be true
this is not true this is absolutely
false it's not secure I do think that
one the iPhone face recognition
technology is like universal I could see
that happening but that I having that I
probably won't be a life for that not
everyone can afford to buy that
expensive iPhone with the fancy face
recognition right man right now it's a
perhaps one day or do you just keep
doing it with paper who cares correct
don't believe that BS most people can't
vote online or via text but you can
register which all y'all should be doing
great you are gonna be 18 by November to
vote online by clicking here and there's
gonna be a little link in this video
yeah okay good
cuz if it were true I'd be worried I
mean yeah good great
that is you okay this is a long 100
readings the outcome of the 2016
presidential election came down to a
group of voters so small they could fit
inside a football stadium
oh it's like one of those like math word
problems that you hate was a popular
poem because that was millions it's true
I'm gonna say false it's basically
electoral ecology
right no I never heard about this I
didn't know what I mean because it can't
work out like that
I'd say positive because I don't know
anything I ever heard about this like
specific things and it also be very
upsetting both balls this is a trick
question because I know that Hillary won
by like over a million others now in the
popular vote oh sorry excuse me but no
they're not talking about popular what
they're talking about the margin of
error right but she lost it over the
electoral electoral college exactly so
initially it was like no because I know
she wanted the popular vote Ryan's by
over a million but now they think about
it
there must have been a state than 150
gossipy it must been like that one state
that like made the decision of the sway
rate you see I'm gonna say both but I
don't know what the actual numbers work
true I feel like it might have been
pretty close because it doesn't I'm so
confused even how this one works because
it doesn't it like an electoral
collector popular well cuz I think the
fact of voting is like you're voting for
your representative seat to vote for
you're like where you live right yeah
no I'm doing true I'm gonna take fall
just because like I want to know but
something may be true I think it might
be true okay let's play it you ready go
Oh despite losing the popular vote
Donald Trump was able to win the
electoral college by fewer than 80,000
votes has Vanity Fair noted this means
that the voters who determined the 2016
election could all fit inside of a
football stadium what yikes
yeah this is politics is fun maybe we
need to get people registering at
football stadiums that sounds good like
a hot dog and the register to vote and
it's not even for people to vote in my
personal opinion but for people's own
personal opinion to be heard because
everyone deserves the right to be heard
all funny stuff aside there were so many
people that didn't vote I also don't
know much about politics and things like
that so I'm like ill-informed
it's not too late to learn it's also has
something to do with the education
system but I do know that mitochondria
is the powerhouse of the cell well and
midterm elections are really important
because the deal you elect during your
midterm election I think are the people
who have an effect on the idea of
college but I'm not sure but no you're
right to pay attention to the down
ballot like that that's the kind of
stuff that makes change like you don't
just make one fake decision every four
years for your country like their stuff
happening me around that you should be
you know involved in get on Twitter
follow them hashtags whoa I cannot this
is this is great like that's cool that's
a mock receipt though like shout out
identification is required to vote in
every single state I hope I see that's
gotta be true I'm pretty sure I did not
have to show my ID last time I went to
vote I don't think you need to show it
in every that's every single state but I
think in some states false are you
serious no that's that can I go back and
forth with this because here's the
problem not everyone has the means to
get a driver's license but every citizen
does need some sort of form of ID okay
maybe it is true the question is not
should it be required as like is it
required and I think it is because what
I've learned from this quiz not every
States to say well they're like all
sisters so oh wait but like you can do
mail-in ballots and you don't have to
like send in your ID yeah okay I'd be
concerned if they originally is it true
but now I think it's false cuz of
mail-in ballot stuff and I think some
states even make it harder because you
have to go get more IB stuff right I
don't know the thing is though like
voting is alright we're driving is not
and having an ID is not where voting is
like a thing it needs to be as easy as
possible to vote but it hope it should
be but it's not and also is it a riot if
felons can't always vote can the right
be revoked or is that a privilege I
think it's false
I'm gonna go false oh good my downs I'm
saying this is true you there's an I
believe there's nowhere in America where
you could just show up and be like I
have no ideal any vote they will be like
heaven
having a laugh so let's see okay this is
let me just make sure I'm reading this
right yeah okay sure
or they just like what's I mean or like
yeah you can hahaha I think this one is
false ideas required in many states but
not all oh wait
where where is this freaking state guess
what you can learn more about your state
requirements right here okay I need to
know this no document part of a good
it's all water though California's one
here
I'm not surprised by that but so you
just saw what I don't know they just
trust to you say you are that can't be
that can be that can not absolutely
cannot be like when you just think about
it like you should be that less maybe
it's not like it's not easy or everyone
in getting a driver's license or some
sort of form of foreign identification
and they still have the right to vote
and just because you don't have that
means that you can't vote that doesn't
work that way I mean I agree with that
sentiment I think it's true the usually
ID laws are to get turnout down because
usually people are people students those
are people who don't have like idea I
think the lady was this it's always like
little lady at my polling place and she
like watch your address okay
okay I do mailings every year I've never
actually gotten to I've had to do
absentee ballots every year
last question okay if you don't bring an
ID to the polls and your state requires
it you will be turned away well that's
confusing based on the action I hope
that's false because I think if you
don't need an ID even if your state
requires that you can bring another
proof of my identification like a bill
maybe I don't know based on the last one
and I'll just because I like love rules
if your safe is you you need it then I
feel like you need it
break my leg yeah I want to chop off
it's out well that just sounds like a
legal issue so the true church I think
it's true yes true I think that's also
true if this state requires you to have
the ID that will save you don't have one
goodbye but I also think that if you
forget it you might be able to get a
provisional ballot well I think this
might be true I also think it actually
is false because they do give you a
provisional ballot I'm actually going to
say true like if your state requires you
to have an ID you better have your ID to
vote otherwise they're not gonna let you
there it's required they got us on the
provisional provisional ballot what what
wait provisional ballots are counted
once the state is able to verify your
eligibility to vote so if you forget
your ID or the poll workers cannot find
your name and
be sure to request a provisional ballot
oh that's good tomorrow educate me drag
me drag me says happens you know you
lost your wallet Oh
tried anything of that what have you
lost the night before you want to
greatly part the democracy
I got 7 out of 10
let's not talk about points what did you
get just got 6 out of 10 I filled right
when it comes to voting you know fat
from fiction when it comes to voting
I know fact from fiction too just a
little bit less my parents would have
been like that's not a name blood oh
yeah you know the fact from fiction heck
yeah man Gotham State Education no your
policies tall your reps
there's always solar Mike the politics
are so intimidating and scary to me
sometimes I feel the reason why I don't
have a lot of the political
conversations is because I'm afraid of
looking dumb today I need to get over
that fear and be willing to learn sign
those petitions bottom 5
foots asleep so I get up immediately
what'd she say I think we did well today
and we all learned something wait Julian
I learned that you need to get out and
vote it is actually easier than we
thought it was I think it's crazy that
this past election was decided by 80,000
people a football stadium of people
determined who is the leader of this
country it's cool it means democracy
like any other day whether you like the
one or not
democracy is kind of cool no matter what
your political stance is you should all
agree on one thing and that is to vote
there is a link below that you can click
and it'll only take a few minutes and
you can actually register to vote right
now so do it you have no excuses
you do it do it very if you wanted
there's your friends and see how little
they know about voting make them take
the quiz and then you can take it too
and not tell them that you already saw
this video and look real smart in front
of them with that link right below the
other link somebody likes please
register and I'm calling you out
no calling your mom the calling your dad
your grandma and that aunty you don't
like and I want to tell her that you
didn't vote don't forget to subscribe
you know you better be fun learn no
spotless of you better about both but
you better know your policies call you
back
arvo okay let's try it again from the
top ty okay right that's right what you
know kissing again true how can I talk
about Kersey hell yeah okay cool
does that causing right oh yeah I think
we're Busbee that's fine I think that
wasn't in the email
[Music]